you know what it is there right there we
go about 105 boom I can't we got into
the intern in the building with in my
opinion currently the best hip hop group
in the world run the jewels killer Mike
and LP v competition how did over there
we got groups I like who do you like
right now who do I hold oh I love as I
got a two kisses I got too old and then
I got groups with I agree with this
skill you got it
among troops right now we loved and
listened to race your gentlemen that's
where he goes now you eat a heart by
heart you know I mean oh we we are we
are happy to be in my office right grew
closer a buyer yes [__] D'Amico's um
Mike you've always kind of like
obviously you're from Atlanta you
started off cancer what he knows yeah
but like being from that part of the
Atlanta culture that necessarily isn't
making the trap music I always had this
discussion with rich who's obviously
another guy from Atlanta yeah but it's
like a little bit harder to break out of
that Atlanta scene if you're not
breaking the records in the strip club
now obviously now things are kind of
caught on like wildfire with other jokes
but when you were doing the pleasure
leads to the grind stuff in on and
really grinding in Atlanta independently
was that something that you felt was
like hard to like it you know break
through the other thing I just love all
the other love who love you so I'm very
strong following in Atlanta I'm Vishal
follow another pop up reach the place
whether it was deep in Chicago Ill a
Detroit well so I got a chance to travel
like in terms of me maggot rap music I
make crab meat willingly rebels the
trash it I'll invite all right now I'm
also [__] there's all right how called
pots and pans random single lighting the
internet up so but you know for me I
like very ism I like making the type of
music we make so it's good it is
audiences everywhere we just sold out to
having them around 3,000 beautiful thing
is I think audiences the other thing you
just get off your anymore of course
they're now LP obviously you had like so
many stages of your career
I mean you
you know marc-andre one of the most
successful event in violators long time
job to get just job to miss your lips
one of my favorite rappers around should
list and obviously company flow
headaches independence except what's
different though each of y'all had your
own route here black this has to feel
did what feels different about what's
going on with run the jewels right I
mean be honest with you as much as I've
been as long as I've is know is doing
this it was really different changes
that I've gone through and sort of wrote
it out had a lot of different types of
success with different this is the
biggest thing I've ever been tomorrow
I mean risk I mean just just straight-up
like I don't think you might have
personally been involved in something
that's big like this you know it is
crazy - as long as as long as I've been
doing out now I've seen things almost
beyond the birds right above the pig
I've always been very lucky I was been
successful in the sense that I was kind
of strong following you know we are made
a living we always had a strong group of
people who were pursuing what we do who
came to the show so supportive and it's
been amazing but you always heard of you
know there was always has missed the
mythological next level we're tonight as
well yeah we're where the venue has to
get bigger you know knew it wouldn't
work where you have to bring more people
on and make it to make the whole
operation work where you get where you
were all of a sudden fun you know
why not make them yes not you know it
just it is very thrilling but me and my
wife me and Mike were happy doing do we
were going before we met we both had
like strong no basis that you have
worked really hard for that we were
happy when it combined those two bases
made for a solid base for improvement
that we could do whatever we wanted to
do in terms of having a healthy career
making a record just wanted to make so
it going somewhere bigger than that it's
just it's a surprise and it's something
that we're really sort of maze but but
we were cool with being where we were
you know so it's like we're already
everything is a bonus round right now it
would love to you know everything is
like a pleasant surprise everything is
kind of over time and in and you know
for us we already kind of work we
already are a bar you know it doesn't
happening with 121 so when I'm freaking
out we're not losing our aqua we are
we're not no it is just the pleasure to
me to see at you know any because worthy
of whatever say people possibly in the
red light yeah Mike what about you
obviously you know you had a lot of
success but you were also without cash
and you saw success that success you
know dialyzer dr. Harris is but um you
know how do you feel that was going on
you guys are you know there are orders
is more the biggest change that realize
it's a real it's it's like you get
trapped into the game that goes to the
Super Bowl
but largely a marginal role right right
right lighting you up there you or you
put it that's not the time is going to
attain and no one expected anything from
franchise around like essentially we
went to an advantage being that we've
been welcome back to back to back
that's real you know and hello from the
way I thinking yeah yeah yeah baby the
cheerson I'm not even sports fan and I
want a very are connector one is Jules
being number one in hip hop rnb
and on the Billboard and plugins I was
winning and one here with just make
money there be the better your effort
here is my what did you find out get a
phone call people's reaction little
together the more level I got a home
what's crazy is my own I knew last week
we came in at 35 is my drug dealer best
friend going on this ball right
it is and we have a text from our
management that was happening out like
wild but it's dealing hit me until I saw
it go up the week there we go and went
up doing come out overwhelm and you know
you to make it go everybody died in a
day I'll come out like I'm here to get
out literally everybody with a good
person yeah I hear your bags and what
the year do they exactly there you go
and then but really no really isn't that
me knew that we had torque on yeah and
we were looking at what we were dropping
it and we were like what we're scheduled
to drive about like three days after the
tour start with it or like technically
as I believe it and we were like you
know we couldn't figure out what we were
waiting we just couldn't figure it out
we're like wait wait like what would be
we're putting the work it out ourselves
there's no label or anything just that's
why I let this is like just our
operation and this is the first time
that because we haven't met two people
for that your last time who votes for
that we're still doing our math skills
is fulfilled I was right right so
currently it's a hundred percent up next
we look at that law [__] beautiful
okay hey guys what specifically yang
said except it's right now so this is
the one version that actually takes
matters Oh awesome an 82 is my favorite
version and it just not my guy at 17 5
on his neck right down yeah literally
will now experience is going to know a
little bit more modest I'm waiting I'm
not getting on prices places okay I need
anything out here I got I said what I
said I can't wait to embarrass you
because I'm getting a full-size baby
monkey yo like at what point um I would
you know obviously like full [__]
butane or like to me the first real run
the jewels record a no no butane and
tougher cold express right that's right
yeah but rap music to me was such an
important out like rap music is a
classic spice in Soho
and it's really what kicked off is dope
beautiful relationship but win I mean
did you guys realize like in a way what
you guys just working and you guys had
the records done you decide we just puts
down as a group or did you guys make a
conscious effort to tell you all this
pasado WB all you do the rubber tool
yeah the run the tool set because
obviously rap music was incredible
insensible after that first one yeah
yeah no we went on tour because I drop
the records let everybody know we try to
rap music and then I try to hit like
shore jump a week later it just came out
like that and we toured together and
obviously we became friends making his
record and he was on my record and
toured together we have an amazing time
that we will perform Jan our chance
together on stage and we just became
friends what one that oriented I feel
myself going in you as I don't need out
I just oh mom I don't know why I'm doing
affinity and they say something at some
little day I'm going to drop I decide I
was beating this foot so mouth and he
was like I'll do it you know like okay
cool yeah come on you got jump on a
couple jams as I come through number one
album here at mouth example he came
through in the rest of history and we
really step off what I mean he came
through we had a great time we made like
five or six
- but it's true it's like are
transferred in Komal fresh flower that
we love her to rebel get done we don't
like my song that any like Mary got
gradual migration had to make all
records what was it about the chemistry
because either you guys important male
penguin on top distributors to advisers
they were going to feel a lot of dated a
hundred beautiful women I can't tell you
want my life the one it is beautifully
more and everything but she did someone
like yeah [__] each other brother
yelling man use me sir oh you uh
something he's got a weird system to it
my son like it wasn't an hour does your
mom be the bunny yeah I ate every
interval we just we just we just um mm
we're grown-ups we met we you know we
where were of similar minds you know
about a lot of stuff we be able
we had a lot to learn from each other
but also just it was an excitement about
about the friendship of the music and
you know that was really genuine know we
just meet honestly we just love the
record that we were making we had great
time touring when you find that and we
will also interface where we were just
rolling the anatomy we were just rolling
with whatever was happening whatever
whatever and we sound dope together
it has nothing like you got it you got
do not do so that's the rig I do not
you're not smarter than fate so I'm [__]
[__] [__] [__]
come on no no just you can import nobody
else up absorb a little jealous creeper
roof yeah close the door back so shop oh
now am I getting on I get enough of it
I'm strapping yeah I've been like an
hour right now you're fun get to me give
me if this right is right if you just go
just keep doors right now I'm thinking
about it do you think like did you feel
like finding you bounce because your
your eyebrows are like
so aggressive it's like you get to
feeling like when I'm living the
Metallica when I hear you wrapping up
the copper and like is these to me it's
like it's like the same [__] it just
reminds me and some like I know you guys
got back on your chin which are but it
just reminds me of that energy from
range yes I mean that's what I've always
wanted and that's what I found the other
being now look obviously um volunteered
for burning up donating a lot of money
to burning up you were one of his
biggest um you know supporters public
she so [__] up right now I'm not sure
like I like I'm in that movie just a
procedure that we are in I have no I
mean I just I mean I wake up every day
I'm like Jesus what's up in Canada real
stable going hunting but uh only one
other but no but seriously I mean
obviously Mike you've always been
extremely politically driven in all your
music just a reason why are you talking
to me personally but but how do you feel
about well first of all the start was a
burning thing because a lot of people
supported Bernie and you know we let
down and everything to happen to be
intoxicated not even to the nomination
but it but how do we keep that energy
moving forward and then let's talk about
this Donald Trump shade of this puzzle
thing and Todd's an enjoyable absorb
organization specimen I joined it to our
revolution in will be an organization
which we organize locally stop danger
Arizona never rabbit Americans in
particular they call me unpack get us
off this we put persecuted they can
attack a local election I started I just
didn't fall over whether councilmen with
school or and the Orioles that are
coming up but you get it like the Sam's
campaign is endorsed the money the
Atlanta you should
that is really that big and you know our
campaign in the property exactly what
needs to be an aggravation the aggressor
without an apartment president we got we
got president regret if you don't like
what he's doing pay for the street like
you did last night if you and I saw
everybody next for you and he'll make it
he'll wherever you go that's it may be a
trick him but them for their zippy
become full part yeah you would pack
them all fun that's it you got it in two
years you gotta go get them yeah you got
your letters yeah there you go you know
what going to do it didn't you're
talking us through a couple years ago
we've closed you man Tony I don't even
both literally just you know and I'm not
ashamed of their first I had a reason
behind us um you know the way I saw Rick
what you're talking to who now is more
interested in hurting them at their game
that is that that thing is in sitting
out because whatever that that's playing
feel that you're going to be on your
because I don't like to candles I mean
I'm not going to come and break I don't
move and that's it you know I don't like
the game but you know we're not really
playing a game and I think that we have
the and I thought I'm sorry to me to go
to test a little bit apparently she
would happening right now
and I don't I don't I don't think it's
wrong it's not just turning lovers and
possible workers peasants just the great
eyes and I think that we have the
benefit we're generation on the benefit
of seeing some real assortment is not
too far away that that not on
[Music]
unrecognizable as a parallel between
what could happen in those countries now
than what has happened to us as a short
of 50 years ago yes and I think that
there this means is mistake being made
by these people
the mistake is that they prematurely
assume and everybody forgot and that
everybody's bigger another station is
gap in time is it long enough that
people are either uneducated but
interested in more of our more or
unwilling to act upon the homeland
respond to that memory UNITA may have
that the cultural memory and so I do
believe that it's interesting when you
watching my eyes do believe that know
what's going to happen but I do believe
those things that we're going on
really a bigger fight is going to go
down and if there's a positive to be
taken away from being elected people are
actively now
at least you'd like to happen I mean
obviously anybody can post a meme on an
on Instagram but it's people without
anybody can go take over Japan
everything I can every flower in Italy
I'm gonna go I said I was following my
videos I'm from a problem lot of cicadas
come city to the country a lot of people
but a man look if we all get like that
about all oppression all depression my
where I'll get if that happens because
of stopping prison oh that happens
because of gay marriage to happen
portion right does that happen every
single time what happened last night in
the Pensacola initiatives after the
romantic comedy camera Atlantis my
important skiing process pretty super
yes it could also also go and then our
mayor for whatever reason I thought his
white folk they had officially started
coming up with a plan to make sure the
Chinese will not be disrespected not
even Sony I believe even though there
was a federal position on them they are
one of the here for the things we've
done more to accommodate to meditate you
know the following general dollar energy
for not mistreated so how that criminal
yeah I just always got to tip my hat
anytime I see things like that happen
because you know our mare would be able
to control all the girl we got those
Democrat
looking on but he would really get some
politically local politicians and
courageous is knowing that with such a
national fever attack um at beyond
anything that like Ian Mike and under
the stage every night
and the spite decides that there is the
bringing of - very legit like literally
politically active but we're both very
very
sociologically like we both we both
online and we've always test things you
know in our music because we care about
we mmm and we also we share the same
repulsion for people who abuses of power
for people who would accuse anybody else
and it's something us you're both listen
what we get on stage every night and try
and so people and people in the ideas a
but you know something that might sauce
reiterated which is that you are
actually free and to remember that you
know that freedom is in it and I agree
that freedom is not something that you
are fighting for it's actually so we're
dependency as an inalienable right is
the thing that is a human right that
happens when you were born onto this
planet and I think that you know more
than anything our community our
sensitivity because of humanity's think
that is outside of politics that are not
specific to opaque but they're specific
to a bigger idea which is cool large who
are we are we people who stand by and
watch of all these hard people
where exactly are we not and if we are
those people that we better be willing
to be caught up so we better be willing
to me shrunk off into a [__] cancer
these better be willing to be put down
or we better be able to stand up as you
know and and so it you know right now
this we know the reason I've always not
been specifically political it's just
because closest difference different
upbringing special perspectives but but
also these issues they float over to the
dinner which I don't share right but you
can always recognize okay now this is
nothing new no one's coming up with any
new plays right you know if this is
something that old and it's something
that's been proven to be disputable Mike
I'll be like right best is ran for
office with a lot of time and I sorted
it with that count shade around fifty
all want great guy to here I can you see
yourself running process in the future
no no put a lot of money
I thought is the sunnatullah' can end
run the ball I want to die tail but
hands over top of API who did I should
be the president a trivial problem and
got out got a president like the United
States but I think the motional CBB is
an angry old man on my school board or
City Council or something like I'll be
that mad old guy like you know I'll be
damned if you put a new driveway until
the building is the kids don't have look
like I'm that guy I'm not and I'll be to
do it in the parking lot with the car
right that's that to the cause of it I
didn't get drunk I want to be that
always got upset because I think that
at very base level you know kids like
your kids are genuinely into now not all
they're going to change the future your
mind is different now my tire older
smarter me so if we can just give them
away to to fully blossom their mind I
think that that's the thing is doing
I'll be an unreal Apple but that house
you give you the dollars of that one
time now I'm like laughing I like
smoking I like going straight love my
life my life so I like living a very
Luke Skywalker Aries when I like let
those are the people that politicize me
dramas politicize you know as much as
goodbye Public Enemy Ice Cube I was
close down you're watching uncle Luke
Luther Campbell fight me on big
government my First Amendment right so
you know for me it just become with so
you know I guess I'll be angry about
school and that's the thing about runner
tools it's like you know as women to
them we're not we're not talking you
know that be our exam I get a whole a
whole reading table with me I would like
what we did you the money to the parents
America or I brown and we should give
the money to so we like to use stupidity
and then fun and go grab music as an
ally a mechanism and halides and do
things that we believe in men are good
but we're not making our music about but
this conversation could be have with a
right we can see here it has this
conversation with you but we're not
going to have this conversation in the
form of a song we're going to make you
glad we're going to make you jump around
we're going to make you want to punch
someone in the face or sure you know but
we're not going to you know we're not
going to give you some try
a long conversation about you know
something because at the other day the
Rizzoli reason we're doing this is
because we just have to be true grown-up
to really do have hearts and really do
have mana and think about this stuff and
at the same time we're just making a
move on that musical another level may
like there appear to me there guys do
that [__] so good you're whatever I
can't be for record but I didn't is
definitely but I've always been that in
the course of being the total yeah thing
and I'm understand you're ready like I'm
gonna give you Reagan but on the same
record I got a Gucci I'm you know I'll
just put it I got animal you up and I'm
for real about but I love guys like
bamboo
immortal technique brother are Lisa
shooting tempo I love them so much
because you're an active little cooler a
rather they're doing it and I'm active
I'm an activist but may they pour
everything and that music so for me I
never would I never would fully stake
their claims but I don't want to take
the shine from the people to do with 24
hours a day and are so dope at it like
I'm here because pic immortal technique
took me out on tour or take or anything
yeah you know he took me out and got me
introduced to not only my honey in a
more organized everything exactly so
nice to me man
III glad to celebrate being a part of
that encouragement and collecting those
values but I want people to be as into
bugs for knowing you want to hear the
stupid [__] behind us or the record but
that sounds real personality but I want
you supporting the military I want you
supporting tempo I want you to
supporting them I want you to support it
at the same time for the veto that the
thing is is like we time for everybody
to tap into where who their allies are
and what absolutely and the fact is that
your allies or the people around you
people have to stop from requesting that
goodness and
and your allies call it a package that
looks familiar to you and you hire my
fate yeah you know I hate labels within
you but what are you even just even
within community to like that's not
demanded that the people around them to
have our back are people who we think
are exactly that with that everything
that that every idea and every interest
and hobby and everything out in the
halfway to be looking [__] mines up
listen man I don't care you can get
saved you can get saved from a bullet
from some of the you know they never
either you've never met it there's no
requirement for bravery ah there's no
requirement for for justice they can you
know so except that except bravery and
justice of the soul there's nothing else
there's no other personality trait that
is required you know me and Mike you
know I firmly believe the reward we love
when the group works is because we are
funny and because we and because we talk
[__] and because that's the specter
basis and at the same time we give
ourselves room partially in armies we
give ourselves to be [__] excuse me
exactly how many of you would like to be
[__] yeah but also we are hard to be
allies enough to stand up you know
and that's how we are with each other do
you feel like since you guys started
making music together you have like
elevated each other skill set tell you
because I feel something I've been a
I've been a big fan of healthy for a
long time in every system rocket game
and I feel like your rap is better that
you go to rap and I always start feeling
like it's more of the nights on the
whole [__] plan thank you so much but
it's like real sharpen skills
straight-up real sharp Manhattan I
always feel like welcome to one of most
underrated producers in the game okay
and with the success of run the jewels
has there been a has your inbox been
what it's by artists that it might not
have otherwise reach now performance
obsessed like are you working with any
other artists or is this strictly one
the jewel if only you knew if only you
knew this I would I can I can't say the
name right but yeah I will I would make
them blush I would if it wouldn't isn't
wasn't really all the night I put it on
this way I put it to you this way yeah
should we get a big one you know there
was like like what Jamie hit night I
wonder what little brother was popular
yeah kind of like that kinda like that
it's been amazing but at the same time
like you know we've gotten where we are
because you've been working on
where the tools is flat for me I will do
this one with all the amo never became
sorry never been with all the UH you
guys are doing a lot of tech schools now
yeah
coming up there's I know there's a bunch
of stuff you guys are working on it but
what has been like so far your guys's
that's the moment as run the jewels at a
live show what's that light moment very
time you say it today better changes
like I would I would have told you Billy
I mean I'll Pittsburgh a few nights ago
and we went to Atlanta and we've set a
tabernacle on fire like I haven't said
on partners out game no and you there up
in some surely or some iconic one sent
albums like once if any will work for
the rights of the blooming season I read
everybody was once that I would submit
for this for the movie on there was some
you know just not necessarily because it
was a normal great show but because
there was something different events on
power lines
what we were in a fabulous tonight that
the
burning down that was a very powerful
moment known as a very intense and
powerful moment where everything felt
more magnetized everything that we said
all of a sudden that were meeting every
day was you know because there have been
moments rather than just very blown away
like while we're we're somehow finding
ourselves in the center of something
very powerful and significant and in
struggle it's not not not because we
didn't creating around what we just
found ourselves in these moments and I
mean we were able to stand up and be who
we were and have the right not at the
right time had that moment matter and it
felt very much like Kanan is when a
weird what you know like works like I
don't know if that would have been able
to in the same if we were young you know
if they were in our twenties and we had
done ourselves that moment I don't know
if it would have had the same impact you
know so every it did away those moments
refine ourselves or allow everything
I've been doing in my life if anywhere
if anything had changed I wouldn't have
been here with my friend in this moment
and it felt like we needs to be there
and up to is there's different some
pretty amazing talking about the voices
you guys have and
[Music]
well they're specific reason on the
album are you guys believers and Trump
on I believe management we're not making
a news record we're making human record
we're making a fun read we're making a
rap record like he's lucky he got
mission unanimated I clear it up not not
well now we're not making record to
reflect what's happening this you know
this year we're making records that
means we were to listen to a sortie and
the same struggles of power and human
influence and jimin's you know empathy
and humor should apply you know as
applies for him if you had only Dylan in
the comic book yeah he's not even close
there's something he's lucky and even
misses he's lucky he's even got loose
the even Gaillard got it and then the
grant was rating you deep humming I'm
not eating I'm asking is on tonight
we're getting freaky Russia but shout
out the killer Mike set up a healthy
project out in the beautiful new album
is dirty Atlanta gold slash after 10
p.m. in Venice at our door go to my
belly right Michael we're tranquil two
cycles second session strongly in New
York employs a zoo just because they
can't be our so-called law in time I
magazine you cannot go anywhere you tell
that we're at my G oh my god get it or
yell or I don't know whatever they have
a partner on all this recipe even on a
palpable yes but an obvious my business
there's so much other stuff you guys
always you know on the jewels head legs
what what is coming out is there you
know a half a video game and what oh
yeah one day I'll tell you one thing
that one month answer is that we're
doing authentic reality so anybody who
bought the album cover and anybody who
bought the CD
where anybody about anything physical
that has the rubber jewels they get a
t-shirt or anything we haven't had that
you can download and you can find it on
the instructions where on our website
you would get it on your phone and you
put that up there and it creates more
animated content it's been in that so in
other words if we come and it's going to
constantly update we're going to send
you videos like if you go right now and
you take my phone you look at the vinyl
all but you'll see money raining down on
on a picture so I solve it saying I know
I could do another as a fan you guys put
out a semantical record now I'd run the
dual challenge in [__] hat oh well
you love although again for the love of
God are you both up or down appreciate
y'all the Shane is heavier I don't know
how you wear you can't wear it all day
no I only wear it before and if people
step out of line it's also well weather
yo is this time I will save you're in
Paris go to the little Museum this is
actually does not rapper jooheon of
people are call the winged victory of
the motorist or you kids out there so
global google their job is rolex yeah
bro disposition it sweetheart